SO VON STEUBEN
SHOWS UP WITH COOKS
AND BUTLERS.
HE'S DRESSED TO THE NINES.
HE'S WEARING FURS.
HE'S GOT A DOG,
AND HE SAYS,
HEY, I'M VON STEUBEN.
HE LOOKS AT ALL OF
GENERAL WASHINGTON'S SOLDIERS,
AND HE SAYS,
LOOK AT THIS GROUP OF DOGS.
THEY'RE DYING.
THEY'RE STARVING.
THEY HAVE NO AMMUNITION,
NO LOVE.
THE SOLDIERS ARE LIKE,
I DON'T LIKE THIS GUY.
GEORGE WASHINGTON SAYS,
NO, NO.
GIVE HIM A CHANCE.
AND VON STEUBEN'S LIKE,
I AM GONNA WHIP YOU GUYS
INTO SHAPE.
NEW COACH IS IN TOWN.
VON STEUBEN STARTS
TRAINING THE SOLDIERS,
RUNNING THEM THROUGH THE RANKS.
HE'S STRETCHING THEM
THROUGH THE STRETCHERS.
HE'S YELLING AT THEM
IN PRUSSIAN.
AND THEY GO,
WHAT'S HE SAYING?
WASHINGTON IS LIKE, OH, BOY.
THE GUY DOESN'T
EVEN SPEAK ENGLISH,
SO HE SAYS,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
BLAH, BLAH.
AND THEY HEAR,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
BUT GUESS WHAT.
A YOUNG CAPTAIN SHOWS UP--
BEN WALKER.
HE SAYS, I CAN UNDERSTAND
ALL THE BLAH-BLAH-BLAHS.
I SPEAK PRUSSIAN,
AND I CAN HELP THE AMERICANS
UNDERSTAND HIM.
VON STEUBEN TURNS OVER
HIS SHOULDER AND SEES...
THE MOST HANDSOME AMERICAN
HE'S SEEN SO FAR.
STEUBEN'S INTO BLONDES
AND THIS GUY IS PLATINUM BLONDE.
BEAUTIFUL CHEEKBONES,
PUFFY LIPS.
BENJAMIN WALKER SAYS,
I WILL BE YOUR GUIDE,
AND, UH, THEY BECOME BUDS.
BUDS.
- [laughs]
THEY HAVE THIS--THIS--
THIS TRAINING MONTAGE.
[Survivor's Eye of the Tiger]
SO BENJAMIN WALKER ENDS UP
BEING EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEEDED.
HE HELPS THEM WITH THE TROOPS.
VON STEUBEN
STARTS TEACHING THEM THINGS.
HE'S LIKE, THESE ARE KNIVES.
YOU CAN USE THEM
TO STAB PEOPLE.
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
OH, THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
HE TEACHES THEM
HOW TO CLEAN THEIR TEETH.
TEACHES THEM
HOW TO CLEAN THEIR BODIES
SO THEY DON'T GET DISEASE.
PEOPLE WERE LIKE, WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO WIN A WAR, MAN.
AND HE WAS LIKE,
THIS IS HOW YOU WIN A WAR.
- ♪ IT'S THE EYE
OF THE TIGER ♪
- THEY START TRAINING HARDER,
AND THEN HE SAYS,
BEN WALKER, YELL AT THEM
IN ENGLISH,
AND THAT GUY SAYS,
MORE SQUATS.
MORE SQUATS, COME ON!
HE LITERALLY CHURN--
HE CHURNED--
HE CHURNED THE ARMY
INTO BUTTER.